yeah hello welcome to this video is this
right now yeah now it's right it's a
problem with them adjusting the window
let's go for some day ours I've played
lots of e45 lately too yeah deepen
that's the wrong sentence to hit yeah
and you to practice a little bit down
let's go for something else go for a
fully door key great chileno is that the
chill aenean tiger or something like
that yeah Spanish they sometimes have
really cool sounding name Sam okie dokie
never saw that one yeah White's main
moosian idea three or the caption yeah
this is also not bad going for something
with g3 now on a tree and g4 even or
this yep also possible so quick g4 very
aggressive mr. Teague Rachel anal yeah I
definitely don't want a quick g5 to
happen so I'm going age six and now get
some pawns roebling on the queenside
yeah how to play this Knight a5 doesn't
seem very dangerous at the moment but
maybe I can attack this night I don't
know if he wants to go to a form that
looks a little bit off yeah okay and
here maybe even d5 as a move it looks a
bit its aggressive let's put it that way
but loose maybe but
okay very quick reply I thought that
this would require some more yeah some
more contemplation but he just banged it
out okay maybe we should be seven so
that I can no I'm threatening to take of
course white is reacting in no way and I
was threatening to take and place your
faith I was thinking sorry my voice is a
bit off I it's a bit difficult if you
have a slight coat to do the recordings
but the court should stop me from
posting daily videos so no worries okay
um kiss going back I mean I can't just
take euphoria by gaudí for that I mean
this is just just looks good right
ninety-five was also very very decent
choice
yeah but he cannot ignore this now if he
cancels long i'll take f3 yet that's
never going to be enough compensation
yeah this move yeah baby so let's go to
be 6 angling for 94 and just trading
queens I mean I've won a big Center born
okay jack happy to do that now wait just
not so quick yeah that's good it's good
and now I want to check that night air
that be sure I'm sorry it looks already
completely winning this position both
night moves probably a good don't see a
big difference in quality there jack
yeah so let's check this what is the
best move what's most convincing Knight
f3 Windsor look or let's say the
exchange and well it's quite
it looks like it's enough but i still
wonder if this occurs if there's
something better even rook e8 on
something like that we are not sure if i
spend more time I can check on c3 King
III but I don't see a great jack great
point there I'll just take the material
check
ok let's open up as quickly as possible
for the rooks
ruby three coming up
check-check
I'm absolutely taking everything here or
says something better now chief or maybe
it's also a lot of bad wolf also looks
pretty strong
we have taken c2 as well but constable
choice check got 92 94 m check so it's a
piece now that's even easier than an
exchange of yeah that's okay I either
get an F porn on okay ya see 49 f 2 it
doesn't make a difference it's just a
piece
yeah not much to white resides yep that
was the only thing had a neck was close
to saying he could resign it it's really
kind of pointless yeah I don't know why
can't play in this kind of aggressive
fashion but it wasn't particularly well
timed so I don't know maybe you should
flick in a three year so that before
it's not hitting immediately I mean this
this already looks pretty comfortable
for black I mean okay you can argue that
I spent time on many pawn who sets true
but I'm not much behind a development
and well he's got a couple of weaknesses
and this is not exactly ammonius yeah
age three I could have taken here
already but I was unsure I mean this
this is not not so clear does this kind
of thing oh I have this I can take this
I didn't spot this otherwise i would
there would have gone for that it's
funny the engine is not even that
convinced and gives white compensation
here yeah the night when c6 is kind of a
big problem Queenie to add long castles
the engine is on equal completely equal
crazy hmm
yeah okay i decided to prepare that a
little bit and he ignored it simply and
yeah now i'm clearly better I mean that
was the clear idea with Bishop e7 but
you didn't react to it Tim okay he went
back it's just a choice between various
evils I was thinking about this more I
thought this would be more yeah more
aggressive more irritating I don't know
if I should go for this now it could be
check could be tricky I mean this is
approaching very serious proportions
it's even losing you should go here and
and go from them maybe I mean I can
always go also d4 that's not a
particularly bad move but it's not what
I wanted the engine likes this giving
away that pawn and then play Queen to c7
it's not particularly intuitive
especially considering that you cannot
Cass along quickly as f 7s hanging well
that's a total mass this position I'm
also taking the night yangon this is the
computers main line the test is being
slightly better for black yeah
very difficult okay and this is pretty
much pretty much over it's got no good
way of yeah playing now this is chance
is not helping yeah but it was already
just lost yeah what is the best move
there i'm pretty sure that i have a
better look than taking the route but
well it's not bad getting a look for
free or the exchange yes c4 is the
engine move probably preparing Bishop to
c5 yeah it's minus seven it's quite
funny that the engine gives Bishop d3
now as the best move completely
ridiculous looking move yeah but I ok
this is winning pretty reliably so i
can't i'm not really checking concerned
with my choice check and check yeah it
was a pretty pretty clear win he should
try to fight better on them the final
opening stages like here after Bishop d7
you you have to react somehow to that
idea of playing takes and c5 and T
simply didn't ok thanks for watching